FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to this video.
We're going to be talking today
about Pythonistas experience
learning Go.
So I'm Francesc Campoy Flores.
I'm a developer programs
engineer for the Go team
at Google in Mountain View.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
I'm Brian Dorsey.
I'm also a developer
programs engineer.
But I'm on cloud
and don't actually
have much experience with Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: OK, so you
decided to learn
Go some months ago.
What brought you
to that decision?
BRIAN DORSEY: Gotcha.
So I've been using
Python for a long time.
I love it.
And-- but there's a few areas
where I think, in particular,
like distributing command
line apps and kind
of-- there's-- and
so, in particular,
that was the one thing that I
was really looking around for.
And I was looking
around languages
and Go looked really,
really interesting.
And in particular, having a
real baked-in concurrency model
was really appealing.
Because I have to
admit, I fear threads.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Threads are-- yeah--
difficult to
understand sometimes.
Yes.
So in are more generic
question, why [INAUDIBLE]
Pythonista learn Go?
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
So definitely, as I mentioned,
the concurrency model
is really appealing.
And there's a lot of different
options in the Python world
for dealing with
currency-- both within one
process and
multi-process and async
and all this other
kind of stuff.
And pretty much every
model is possible.
But I think it's really
nice in Go, where there's
one way to do it
that's baked in.
And it's a lot easier to
get your head around it,
I think, because of that.
So that's one thing.
And then, of course, you've
got a compiled language
that's fast.
It feels, honestly, kind
of like a Python XE to me,
as a Python person.
And the approach to
object orientation,
through what kind of feels
like duck typing to me,
is pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
So yeah, maybe it
feels like duck typing.
Go doesn't have
duck typing though.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Duck typing is something
that-- so as you very well
know from Pythonage when
if it looks like a duck and
quacks like a duck, then
it's a duck.
And if it's not a duck,
it will fail at run time.
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: In Go, it
will actually fail
at compilation time.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
So it's not duck typing.
It's called
structural sub-typing.
And it's kind of like if you had
an explicit statically checked
duck typing.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
So probably that-- yeah, that's
a better way to think about it.
So I guess a good
example for Python people
might be, we have
something that-- we'll
say this object is file-like.
So you can kind of, op,
you can read from it,
and you can write to it,
and that sort of thing.
And-- but the list
of exactly which
methods, can you also
open it or close it,
or can you seek on it
or things like that?
Which ones are actually
included in that?
It's not clearly
defined all the time.
And in Go, you might have an
interface that is like the--
or you do have an interface.
It's the Read Writer, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yeah,
there's Reader, there's Writer,
there's Read Writer.
Also, you were saying Seek.
So there's Read Seeker.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, and
so each one of those
is a specific
collection of methods
with their exact
signature, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: And so the
compiler can know exactly when
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: And then you
can write a function that
receives as an argument, a Read
Writer.
And you know
exactly what you can
do the map-- on that object.
You can do read and write.
BRIAN DORSEY: Right.
So locally, you're
reading the code,
and you can tell what it can do.
So that's awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Yeah, that's great.
So now that you've
been programming
for-- how long have you
been programming in Go?
BRIAN DORSEY: I basically
did a learning project
for a couple of months.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: OK.
BRIAN DORSEY: So not a
huge amount of experience,
but made one little project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
OK, so but after-- yeah,
after these couple
of months, what
were the things that
surprised you the most?
BRIAN DORSEY: So
I think probably
the biggest surprise
is error handling.
And I feel like I got
surprised by that twice.
One, in that-- I had
this initial reaction of,
wait, this is the modern world.
Why am I having to deal with the
error from every single call,
right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: And pretty
much anything where
there's something that can
go wrong-- And it's software,
so things can almost always--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Everything can go wrong.
Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: You get this
error [INAUDIBLE] thing
back from the call, and you
have to deal with it locally.
And that really surprised me.
And then I feel like working
through an actual project
with it, I came to
really, really like that.
So take networking
as an example.
You're going to open
a socket and try
to do some stuff with it.
And there's so many things
that can go wrong there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Yes, everything.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
it's kind of unclear,
looking at a local piece
of Python socket code,
whether-- which errors
are handled, right?
Because it could
be handled locally.
It could be handled in a
wrapped exception somewhere.
You have to kind of
know the whole code base
to know where that's at.
And in Go, it's right
there in front of you,
on the screen-- page
you're looking at.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: And of course,
you can decide, well,
if anything goes wrong,
then I just have to abort,
because I can't continue.
But it'll be
written right there.
And if you want to handle all
of the various corner cases,
then that's also
kind of laid out
right there in front of you.
So I've come to
feel like the error
handling is very powerful.
And I almost feel
uncomfortable without being
able to see it in front of me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
So you think that now,
when you write Python code, that
you write kind of ghost style
error handling in
Python or not really?
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm a little
more careful about the errors
that I consider upfront.
I've-- my tendency, in the
past, has been to just write it
and then bang on it, and
oh, OK, that happened.
Add a--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Gotcha.
Everything that is failing and--
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, exactly.
And then you don't--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
I used to do that too.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, still do.
But-- and I think that's
kind of the way to go.
You want to have a test suite
that covers all of your cases.
But I guess I feel like
it takes me-- yeah, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: Yeah, so do
you think that,
therefore, since you're
writing all this extra
code for handling errors,
do you think that's a good
thing, that's a bad thing,
it takes you longer?
Is it worth it?
BRIAN DORSEY: It's
absolutely worth it.
And I feel like-- so
yes, it takes me longer.
Part of that's because
I don't know Go as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: OK.
Fair enough.
BRIAN DORSEY: But
also, I think it just
takes me longer to work
through the logic of it.
And overall, I feel like
that's actually a good thing.
I feel like it takes
me longer to work
through this flow and the
cases that I need to handle.
And I feel more
confident in the result.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: OK.
Yeah, that's good.
So now that you are almost
a Go expert already--
BRIAN DORSEY: Two months of--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: --what
could be your advice to people
that-- probably Pythonistas
are curious about Go.
What could be your piece
of advice for them?
BRIAN DORSEY: So the main thing,
I think, would be, one, try it.
It's absolutely worth
your time to learn Go,
because you will get the ability
to use a new language that
complements Python really well.
But also, the tooling
around Go really
helps you, like from a software
engineering standpoint,
write good code more
quickly, faster.
There's a whole bunch
of things in that area
you can read about.
But it's really true.
And getting in the
habit there, I think,
helps your habits writing
Python code as well.
So we can do all the same
things in the Python world.
We just have dozens of different
options for each of them.
So I think it's helpful
to have this one path
and get in the habit
fo doing things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
The good way to do it.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, your code
is all formatted this way.
And so Go has Go Format.
And Python, we have PEP8.pi.
And just use PEP8.pi.
And I think there's some good
lessons back and forth there.
But the other thing I want
to just kind of mention
is there's some
things that are going
to feel really
awkward-- weird when
you're starting to learn Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Such as?
BRIAN DORSEY: So one
is-- the air handling
is kind of one example of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: OK, yes.
BRIAN DORSEY: And there's a
bunch of those throughout.
Or you look at a
library, and it doesn't
feel like there's enough
code there to really do
what you want to do.
And I really encourage people
to give the Go way a try, right?
So give the air handling
a shot before knocking it.
Actually really try
to write some code
and see how it affects your
experience with the code.
And if you have
some library that
looks like it just can't
possibly work, try it.
And I found over and over
again that there was actually
plenty of functionality there.
And I was able to write the
stuff I wanted to write.
So I think that has helped
me, from a design standpoint,
think about, how little code can
we have to make this really--
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: There
was this talk that [INAUDIBLE],
a very good one.
It's called "Less is
Exponentially More."
BRIAN DORSEY: Ah, OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY
FLORES: So yeah, that's
exactly that point of sometimes
having a little less code
is actually a good idea.
Yeah, so thank you very much
for sharing your experience.
OK, so what could the
Pythonista watching this video
do next if they
want to learn Go?
BRIAN DORSEY: So that's easy.
Go to tour.golang.org.
We'll put the link up.
And it's a web-based
introduction
walk through to the Go
language that's interactive.
You type Go programs, you
hit a button, and they run.
And it takes you from
the very beginning,
all the way up through
concurrency exercises
and everything else.
So when you have a
few hours, sit down
and get started with that.
I think it's very worthwhile and
really helps you read about Go.
But a couple hours
doing that will really
internalize what it feels
like to actually use Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: Great.
Well, thank you very much
for those pieces of advice.
And thank you very
much for watching.
Bye-bye.
BRIAN DORSEY: Take care.